la scène où grande tient dans ses mains
un oeuf de dinosaure qui visiblement a
été pondu dans la nature est dit l'adn
amphibie c'est marrant quand même comme
cela semble être de la culture générale
pour lui de savoir que l'adn de
grenouilles qu'on a injecté aux
dinosaures leur permet de changer
spontanément de sexe dans une population
constituée exclusivement du même sexe ça
il le sait mais les généticiens de
jurassic park l'équipe du docteur vous
ne le savez pas eh bien ça ça pose la
question de comment est-ce que alan
grant fait pour savoir tout ça comment
il fait pour être au courant de toutes
ces choses ça va être intéressant d'en
discuter parce que ça va faire appel à
des choses qui auraient été publié très
récemment des découvertes qui colle
directement avec l'actualité
paléontologique du moment on peut
commencer par exemple par l'intelligence
des velociraptor comment est-ce que alan
grant fait pour savoir pour expliquer
avec autant de détails
l'exact stratégie de chasse des raptor
et on sait que quand ils l'expliquent au
jeune garçon qui vient de les insulter
de grosses dindes
on sait que quand ils leur expliquent
ils leur expliquent la véritable
stratégie de chasse des raptor puisqu'on
voit les raptor s'exercer sur robert tu
me donnes tout à la fin du film
donc on sait que alan grant est au
courant de la véritable stratégie de
chasse des raptor alors même qu'ils ne
les a jamais vus faire et là je pose la
question mais quel genre de fossiles
faut-il découvrir pour savoir ça la
réponse est
aucun il n'existe aucun moyen de le
savoir c'est pas que ce qu'il raconte
est faux c'est juste que c'est
totalement indémontrable quel genre de
fossiles pourrait refléter un
comportement aussi spécifique une
stratégie de chasse avec autant de
détails que ça et qu en plus tous ces
détails soient complètement juste quel
genre de faux si l'on peut découvrir
on a des empreintes de pas qui date de
quelques 10000 ans d'êtres humains qui
poursuivait un paresseux géant en
amérique du nord
tout ce que ces empreintes de pas nous
indique c'est qu'il poursuivait un
paresseux géant
on a des fossiles de smilodon de rancho
la brea des fossiles de spécimens très
âgées des fossiles de spécimens qui
était blessé mais qui ont quand même
réussi à survivre au moins jusqu'à ce
qu'il faut s'y lisent donc ces spécimens
ils ont des fractures qu'ils ont réparé
ou alors ils ont plus de dents du tout
donc ils n'auraient pas pu se nourrir
sans l'aide
d'autres membres de la meute donc on
peut dire que smilodon grâce à ça vivez
en meute et donc possiblement chasser
aussi en meute
donc on a des indices qui permettent de
dire si oui ou non des animaux pouvait
chasser en groupe ce ne sont que des
indices et j'en ai fait toute une vidéo
tout un débat complet sur le cas de
détonique us dans une autre vidéo
mais là le là ce dont je veux parler
c'est que ce qu'il décrit pour
velociraptor il n'existe aucun fossile
capable de le démontrer ou de le
débloquer c'est à dire que les gens qui
vous disent que c'est pas comme ça que
chasser velociraptor ils vous racontent
des cracks
c'est pas possible de savoir c'est là où
je veux en venir c'est que ce n'est pas
possible de savoir à ce point là et même
en regardant le cerveau et là je retombe
sur l'actualité il ya tout juste
quelques semaines paraissait la première
je dis bien la première description du
cerveau de velociraptor et encore ce
n'était pas le cerveau complet c'était
juste la partie qui entourent l'oreille
interne
donc on y voit très bien l'oreille
interne on y voit un petit peu le
cervelet mais on ne voit pas grand chose
d'autre donc ça c'était la première
description du cerveau de velociraptor
et tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il
avait un gros lot flow cullers et que du
coup ses yeux étaient probablement bien
coordonnée avec ses mouvements
donc il était probablement bon chasseur
voilà c'est la seule chose qu'on peut
dire à partir de ce bout de cerveau de
velociraptor
on peut pas sur la base de ce qu'on
appelle lé cerveau fossile qui ne sont
en fait que des moulages de la cavité
interne du crâne c'est pas des vrais
cerveau fossilisé tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est juste pro comparer des
proportions typiquement les lobes l'oeuf
actif du t-rex
si vous êtes fan de jurassic park 2 vous
avez entendu dire que le t-rex à la plus
grosse cavité olfactives tout animal
confondues excepté le vautour à tête
rouge
ce qui est vrai en réalité le t-rex a
effectivement la cavité olfactives la
plus grosse de tous les arts cause or
donc dinosaures et oiseaux crocodiles
donc de tous les arts cause hors
confondues en proportion de sa taille
évidemment parce que sinon t-rex à
toutes plus gros que tout le monde le
dire vu la taille du machin mais en
comparaison de sa taille t-rex a les
plus gros labos lf active de tous les
arts cause or et ça le place très très
proche des vautours et les vautours on
sait ont un sens
de l'odorat très développé ça leur
permet de repérer les carcasses c'est
d'ailleurs parmi les seuls d'oiseaux qui
ont un très bon sens de l'odorat
donc on peut dire que le t-rex avait un
très bon sens de l'odorat
d'ailleurs ça fait un petit tacle à la
scène où alan grant met la main sur la
bouche de l'ex pour l'empêcher de crier
devant le t-rex parce que il ne te verra
pas si tu ne bouge pas donc arrête de
crier c'est bon on est hors de danger
ben non en fait le tiraille sylla son
pif qui est juste devant toi et tu sens
le mammifère mouillé donc non le t-rex
tout c'est totalement que tu es là
normalement bref tout ça pour dire que
le cerveau fossile donc ce qu'on appelle
le moulage endocriniens ne nous apporte
pas autant d'informations que vous
espériez peut-être que ça vous
apporterai sur l'intelligence des raptor
en vérité les raptor il avait un cerveau
qui était plutôt de taille moyenne
comparé aux autres dinosaures le seul
cerveau le plus complet qu'on a d'un
raptor c'est bambiraptor et donc
bambiraptor il a un cerveau qui a été
étudié dans le détail et son cerveau n'a
rien d'exceptionnel pour un dinosaure
théropode ya guère que les troodontidés
qui ont un cerveau relativement gros et
encore pas tous et même archaeopteryx
avait un cerveau plutôt petit donc
l'intelligence des raptor déjà ça c'est
extrêmement discuter mais en plus je
peux même en revenir à cet article qui
est paru récemment sur le cerveau de
velociraptor c'est que même en trouvant
des preuves que velociraptor avait quand
même des capacités visuelles assez
développée pour pouvoir chasser il n'en
rappelle pas moins dans cet article que
on a à l'heure actuelle plus de preuves
de charognards que de preuves de chasse
pour velociraptor c'est-à-dire l'épreuve
de charognards c'est quand on voit des
traces très profondes sur les os ce qui
veut dire que l'animal n'a pas mangé le
muscle mais a commencé à rogner les eaux
ça c'est une trace de charognards on a
plus de preuves de charognards pour
velociraptor qu'on a des preuves de
véritables preuves de chasse la seule
véritable preuve de chasse qu'on a pour
velociraptor c'est la fameuse scène de
combat entre le velociraptor et le proto
ceratops donc velociraptor même dans les
oeuvres encore récente
aujourd'hui
on ne sait toujours pas s'il était
chasseur ou charognards alors encore
moins en 1993
être capable de dire exactement comment
chasser velociraptor avec quelle exact
stratégie il employait pour chasser par
contre il ya d'intéressant dans cette
scène c'est qu'il dit cette phrase il
trouvera peut-être le ventre qui
déversent les intestins et sa
contrairement à la stratégie de chasse
de velociraptor ça c'est pas sortie de
nulle part ouvrir le ventre pour
déverser les intestins c'est une
véritable stratégie de chasse qui est
employé par les varans de komodo les
varans de komodo s'attaque directement
aux ventres de leurs proies qui sont
généralement des quadrupèdes donc ça
marche extrêmement bien et en ouvrant le
ventre de la proie en fait la gravité
fait le reste du travail et tu la proie
et on reste toujours sur le cerveau
puisque alan grant est aussi au courant
que tyrannosaure ne peut voir que les
objets qui bouge
or ça c'est clairement quelque chose qui
ne peut pas se voir non plus sur un
cerveau fossile donc ça aussi on se
demande comment alan grant pourrait être
au courant puisqu'il n'existe aucun
fossile qui pourraient démontrer cela il
n'existe rien qui pourrait fossilisés
qui pourrait nous montrer cela en fait
donc il n'existe aucune preuve ni de ça
ni de son contraire par contre alan
grant et surprenamment pas au courant de
certaines choses qui pourtant fossilise
très bien et là on va parler du
dinosaure donc encore une fois on
rebondit sur l'actualité avec la très
récente publication d'une description
complète de dinosaures qui a fait
beaucoup parler d'elle sur les réseaux
sociaux dont john amende nous dit dans
la description du dinosaure
nous savons maintenant que le deal of
honor est en réalité venimeux et c'est
le mot maintenant qui est important dans
ce qu'il vient de dire c'est à dire que
c'est en ramenant le deal of other à la
vie qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il était
venimeux donc ça veut dire que personne
ne savait que le dinosaure et et
venimeux y compris les paléontologues
donc alan grant
donc personne n'avait l'air d'être au
courant que le dinosaure était venimeux
dans l'univers de jurassic park
ok sauf que c'est quelque chose qui en
réalité pourraient se fossiliser si un
animal était venu parce que les animaux
venimeux et notamment les serpents qui
sont capables de cracher du venin comme
le fait le dinosaure ils ne font pas
n'importe comment et
crachent leur venin par les dents c'est
à dire que les petits trous qui ça va
injecter le venin normalement dans la
proie
chez les serpents cracheurs ces mêmes
petits trous en envoyant le venin sous
pression permettent de jeter le venin de
balancer des jet de venin et ça ça
laisse des traces évidentes sur les
dents ça laisse des petits tuyaux ou des
petites encoches sur les dents qu'on a
pu retrouver sur des dents fossilisées
du trias donc comme par exemple celle du
à chito dont du trias d'amérique du nord
donc chez lui à cetto dont on a des
dents qui sont plus anciennes et qui ont
juste une petite encoche sur le côté et
au fur et à mesure de l'évolution de cet
animal on voit les replis de cette
encoches devenir une véritable
gouttières et cette gouttière ensuite
continuent de se replier sur elle-même
pour devenir un tuyau et ça c'est
typiquement la morphologie qu'on voit
chez les serpents venimeux
donc c'est extrêmement intéressant à
voir de trouver un fossile qui justement
montre cette morphologie comme lui à
chito dont on a aussi des exemples qui
viennent de france un arc autorise forme
donc un proche parent des dinosaures qui
s'appelle graouilly dont chedrawi dont
on a aussi ses petites encoches sur le
côté qui indique qu'il était venimeux
comme ua chito dont et le truc bas c'est
qu'on ne retrouve absolument pas sa
sueur d'îlots photo russe et y compris
dans cette nouvelle description de 2020
dit le fond au russe n'a absolument pas
de petites gouttières sur ses dents et
encore moins de petits canaux qui était
capable d'injecter du venin et encore
moins de le balancer mais là où c'est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait pour le
coup ce que alan grant a l'air de ne pas
savoir c'est finalement le seul truc qui
aurait pu être démontrable et c'est là
que ça devient très drôle en fait donc
voilà je trouvais intéressant de pointer
du doigt le fait que en 1993 il savait
déjà des choses et notamment que
dinosaures n'avait pas une dentition de
serpents et ne pouvaient pas cracher du
venin comme un cobra cracheur ou bien
encore que les bulbes olfactifs de
tyrannosaurus rex était bien trop
développées pour ne pas qu'il renifle sa
proie bien avant de l'avoir vu tout ça
c'était connu en 1993 mais à côté de ça
alan grant a l'air de savoir des choses
qui sont complètement impossible à
savoir même avec les technologies mode
années qu'on ne saura probablement
jamais comme la stratégie de chasse
exacte des velociraptor ou bien encore
le fait que t-rex ne pouvait voir que
des objets en mouvement et évidemment la
seule façon d'expliquer ça c'est que
pour les besoins du scénario
le professeur grant avait besoin d'être
un petit futé